dans cette zone frontalière c'est
toujours la confusion qui dominent des
responsables des nations unies ont
indiqué ce soir qu'il faudra beaucoup de
temps et beaucoup de moyens pour établir
des centres de secours dignes de ce nom
dans cette frontière pour l'instant ce
sont les turcs qui ont refusé certaines
interventions notamment celle de la
croix rouge des réfugiés qui rencontrent
surtout des médecins français
les organisations humanitaires doivent
travailler dans des conditions
extrêmement précaires et ne peuvent
souvent que constater l'ampleur du
dénuement de ces hommes de ces femmes et
de ces enfants
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux marié
d'une panne yeahs et laurent pelletier
qu'elle paraît lointaine l'aide promise
dix à quinze jours avant que les corps
ne soient installés par les américains
dix à quinze jours pendant lesquels la
maladie va encore décimé ce peuple bien
sûr les secours s'organisent bien sûr la
nourriture arrive peuple mais elle ne
soignera pas les blesser elle ne gagnera
pas les malades ici enfin un vieillard
sont presque tous atteints de dysenterie
de maladies pulmonaires de malnutrition
sans traitement il risque de mourir en
trois ou quatre jours et il n'y a pas de
traitement ou trop peu parce que les
cures n'existe pas ni réfugiés ils sont
toujours en territoire irakien
ni interne et le haut commissariat aux
réfugiés ne peut rien pour eux si ce
n'est les appeler des exodes est un
terme qui ne leur donne aucun droit
le comité international de la croix
rouge est jugée indésirable ici par la
turquie et le travail des autres
organisations humanitaires est retardée
par les demandes d'autorisation toujours
coincé entre la bonne volonté d ail les
réticences des autres leurs structures
sanitaires et leurs structures toutes
leurs structures administratives ont été
débordés et quand des structures ont
débordé surtout dans un état un costaud
comme celui-là
en mai les militaires et les militaires
contiennent et au fur et à mesure qu'ils
voient qu'ils contiennent
eq l'aide internationale arrive déjà la
suppression qui s'assouplissent un petit
peu
alors insistance persévérance médecins
sans frontières a pu installer une tente
de soi au milieu du camp depuis quelle
que soit l'heure une files d'attentes à
l'intérieur soigné les blessures par
balles les brûlures de bombes au
phosphore mais surtout la déshydratation
qui peut chaque jour des dizaines
d'enfants médecine d'urgence qui ne
suffira pas à peine sortie d'ici les
mêmes conditions de vie proximité au
croupit reproduiront les mêmes maladies
médecine d'espoir aussi mais que tous
n'atteindrons pas ces femmes voulaient
aller au dispensaire de l'autre côté de
la frontière mais les soldats ne
connaissent ni urgence ni désespoir
seulement la consigne on ne passe pas